Dark Souls 3 is coming very soon and if
you're looking to buy it digitally
through your ps4 Xbox one or PC from
software has some sweet bonuses for you
you'll get different stuff depending on
where you pre-order so hopefully you're
not too paralyzed by choice pre-order
from the PlayStation Store and you'll
get a copy of the Dark Souls 3
soundtrack and a dynamic theme the theme
will be available right away though you
won't be able to get the soundtrack
until launch day
we've already reported on Dark Souls
coming to Xbox one backward
compatibility but you can also get it
for free if you preorder the third game
and on PC Steam pre-orders will also get
you the soundtrack plus you'll get the
game for five bucks less if you already
own Dark Souls 1 or 2 and if all of that
still isn't enough for you you can also
get the digital deluxe edition for 85
bucks you'll get the usual pre-order
bonuses depending on your platform of
choice but you'll also get the Dark
Souls 3 DLC as it releases not a bad
deal Dark Souls 3 hits ps4 Xbox one and
PC on April 12th so you've got plenty of
time to snatch up any pre-order bonuses
you want if we hear more about the game
the pre-orders or the DLC you'll hear
about it from GameSpot